[Música]
se cumplieron los primeros 100 días en
El poder del presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva el mandatario
cargó contra el legado de su antecesor
Yahir bolsonaro y reiteró su compromiso
de favorecer a los más necesitados
también resaltó que la transición
energética está en marcha
un nuevo tiroteo en la ciudad
estadounidense de Louisville en Kentucky
dejó cinco muertos y ocho heridos los
hechos ocurrieron en un banco y el
tirador que trabajaba en el lugar
realizó el ataque con un rifle según la
ong
en lo que va de 2023 se han registrado
146 tiroteos masivos
en Perú al menos 10 personas murieron y
25 resultaron heridas luego de que un
autobús se saliera de la carretera y
cayera por un Barranco los hechos
ocurrieron en la vía que comunica la
ciudad de huánuco con lima la capital
del país ampliamos los detalles desde
Lima
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Brasil Porque Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
cumplió 100 días como presidente y en su
discurso televisado prometió un futuro
económico mejor para el país más
acciones contra la violencia machista y
racista y más compromiso en defensa del
medio ambiente sin embargo también
aprovechó para cargar contra su
predecesor Yahir bolsonaro y su legado
que tachó de fascista Lola da Silva ganó
las elecciones con un estrechísimo
margen de dos puntos porcentuales más
Romero nos cuenta más
100 días de Lula da Silva al frente de
Brasil significan 100 días del
expresidente Jair bolsonaro como Némesis
natural del gobierno el actual
mandatario no desperdició la oportunidad
de recordarlo en su discurso de
conmemoración de esta primera etapa de
gestión
siempre digo que si sumas todos los
presidentes de la República desde la
proclamación de la República hasta estas
elecciones la suma de todas las
candidaturas juntas no gastó lo que
gastó este ciudadano en la perspectiva
de perpetuar El fascismo en el país
Lula Busca erigirse como garante de la
Democracia frente a su predecesor
especialmente a raíz del asalto de Los
Seguidores del ultraderechista bolsonaro
a las sedes del Congreso la presidencia
y el tribunal supremo a inicios de año
el ataque más violento a los poderes
brasileños en décadas
[Aplausos]
armonía
Brasil volvió a cultivar la armonía y la
convivencia republicana entre los tres
poderes de los cuales el mayor ejemplo
fue la rápida reacción al intento de
golpe de estado del 8 de enero al día
siguiente de la barbarie los tres
poderes marcharon juntos del Palacio de
Gobierno del plan alto el tribunal
supremo pasando por el Congreso Nacional
para decir alto y claro no al fascismo
Sí a la democracia
pero el asalto del 8 de enero también
demuestra la amplia base que todavía
ostenta bolsonaro
el expresidente Volvió el 30 de marzo a
Brasil después de un exilio autoimpuesto
en Estados Unidos
asegura que no quiere liderar ninguna
oposición pero a la vez afirma que
quiere seguir haciendo política sin
embargo Lula también cuenta con el apoyo
del 41% de los brasileños que consideran
que su gestión ha sido buena o excelente
frente a un 24% que la valoran como mala
o pésima unas cifras que hablan de un
Brasil todavía dividido
en Estados Unidos este lunes se registró
un nuevo tiroteo en el estado de
Kentucky que dejó seis muertos incluido
el tirador y ocho heridos los hechos se
produjeron en una entidad bancaria donde
trabajaban todas las víctimas y el
presunto responsable el presidente
condenó el hecho y criticó el partido
republicano por no lograr un consenso
acerca de La regulación de armas en el
país
un nuevo tiroteo en luta de Estados
Unidos luego de que un joven armado de
23 años irrumpiera en un banco de la
ciudad de Louisville en el estado de
Kentucky las autoridades investigan las
razones que habrían llevado al tirador a
cometer el delito pero confirmaron que
se trata de un antiguo trabajador de la
entidad bancaria que además estaba
transmitiendo en vivo
escuché un clic del rifle y la señora de
mi lado dijo qué diablos y luego
empezaron los disparos no pude verle la
cara pero era un rifle largo
estaba entrando al trabajo y escuché lo
que parecían disparos luego había dos
oficiales de policía y me dijeron que
corriera Así que salí corriendo la
policía local informó que el agresor
murió dentro del banco en medio de un
intercambio de disparos también
agregaron que respondieron a la
emergencia en tan solo tres minutos vía
Twitter el presidente Joe biden condenó
el tiroteo masivo y criticó a los
republicanos por no lograr consensos
para regular las leyes de armas en el
país por su parte el del Estado realizó
una rueda de prensa visiblemente
afectado luego de contar que algunas de
las víctimas eran cercanas a él
esto es horrible
tengo un amigo muy cercano que no
sobrevivió hoy tengo otro que tampoco lo
logró y uno que está en el hospital
Espero que se salve entonces pido sus
oraciones para que lo logre
según la organización
la cual sigue la violencia Armada en
Estados Unidos lo que va de 2023 se han
registrado más de 10.500 incidentes con
armas de fuego incluyendo tiroteos
masivos y suicidios y en noticias
políticas de Estados Unidos el
presidente Joe biden aseguró en una
entrevista a la cadena en bici que
planea presentarse a la reelección en
noviembre de 2024 Así mismo explicó que
su candidatura sería en conjunto con la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris Pese a que
en principio negó estar interesado en
una reelección el mandatario lleva
varios meses haciendo guiños a una
posible aspiración demócrata pero
aseguró que aún no está listo para
hacerla oficial
continuamos en Estados Unidos Porque el
portavoz de seguridad Nacional de la
Casa Blanca John Kirby aseguró el lunes
que Washington ha tratado de
tranquilizar a sus aliados tras la
filtración de documentos secretos del
pentágono que sugiere que el gobierno
estadounidense pudo haber espiado
algunos de sus socios como Corea del Sur
Ucrania e Israel el funcionario destacó
que están haciendo todo lo posible para
identificar la fuente de filtración pero
todavía no lo han logrado el
departamento de Justicia ya lleva a cabo
una investigación criminal para
determinar lo ocurrido
justamente el departamento de Justicia
estadounidense presentó el recurso de
apelación contra la orden de un juez de
Texas que estipuló prohibir la píldora
abortiva mifepristona en todo el país el
gobierno aseguró en el documento que se
trata de un tratamiento seguro y eficaz
avalado por la comunidad científica
desde hace décadas según el juez de
Texas la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos violó el procedimiento
adecuado al dar su aprobación a la
mifepristona sin tener en cuenta el
impacto negativo del fármaco en la salud
pero desde que se emitió la orden el
gobierno se comprometió a trabajar para
garantizar el acceso al fármaco
estábamos preparados para este resultado
y como todos vieron el departamento de
Justicia apeló la decisión de la corte y
está buscando una apelación pendiente de
suspensión pero quiero ser Clara porque
hay mucha desinformación la mifepristona
continua disponible y aprobada por el
momento una vez más la mifepristona
Sigue estando aprobada y disponible por
el momento
al menos 10 personas murieron y 25
resultaron heridas luego de que un
autobús se saliera de una carretera de
Perú y cayera por un Barranco los hechos
ocurrieron en la vía que comunica la
ciudad de huánuco con lima la capital
del país en el autobús de dos pisos se
transportaban 76 pasajeros Francisco
Zacarías corresponsal de France 24 nos
amplió los detalles
al menos 10 personas murieron y otras 25
quedaron heridas tras la caída de un bus
al río rímac en la provincia de
huarochirí ubicada en la parte centro
Oriental del departamento de Lima
reportes de la policía señalan que el
bus de la empresa de transporte
Guadalupe había partido desde la ciudad
de huánuco con destino a la capital
peruana trasladando pasajeros que
retornaban de celebrar la festividades
de Semana Santa cuando a la próxima Arce
al kilómetro 110 de la carretera central
se desbarrancó en un abismo de 7 metros
de altura un escuadrón de bomberos llegó
al lugar para rescatar a los pasajeros
que quedaron atrapados en el bus
mientras la policía Investiga las
evidencias para establecer las causas
del accidente pero uno de los
sobrevivientes Luis Alfredo Vázquez
afirmó que el bus accidentó porque un
camión que hizo adelantarlo en una curva
y al meterse en el camino lo impactó y
provocó que el bus cayera al río sin
embargo las autoridades no encontraron
al otro vehículo afectado en el lugar
del accidente por ahora el conductor el
bus interprovincial que trasladaba a 76
pasajeros fue conducido a la comisaría
de Chila para ser interrogado por
detectives que dirigen las indagaciones
por su parte la superintendencia de
transporte terrestre de personas cargas
y mercancías señaló que fiscaliza el
traslado de heridos y la recolección de
la información sobre el accidente así
llegamos al final de este Informativo en
France 24 a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía y les recordamos que pueden
ampliar todo nuestro contenido en la web
France 24.com quédense con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]